welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and of the many doctor strangest
getting out of hand in multiverse of
madness perhaps the one we know the
least about is this weirdo immortalized
in statue form which folks whether it's
kang in the tva tina's marble corpse for
captain america's shield being stuck to
the statue of liberty can we all just
agree that statues suck like i don't
care who it is can we just stop turning
people into oversized stone or metal
forms where we all have to grovel at
their feet and inevitably fight over
removing them when someone leaks their
search histories but then a lightning
bolt brings the statue to life so
they're 15 foot tall horses trampolines
just plant a damn tree instead
so yeah i totally relate to our doctor
strange's apprehensive squint up at this
ego maniacal monstrosity forget the
utopian manhattan with its vine covered
buildings blossoming trees jewels
vernian wind turbines if it means we
have to worship voldemort i would prefer
a manhattan gradually turning into
sludge oh you thought i meant this
manhattan sure but you know also the
real life manhattan that's turning into
sludge so assuming this doctor statue
means bad news who is he well official
merch releases for the film have
confirmed this strange's identity
opening up an even deeper layer of
multiversal implications as our strange
faces his other selves the illuminati
and the scarlet witch so one of my first
assumptions upon seeing a statue is that
this represents some noble heroic doctor
strange one who might have sacrificed
himself to save the world the way most
statues seek to commemorate some hero
who has passed like perhaps in some
other universe doctor strange found
another path out of those 14 million 600
to five possible outcomes that would
have defeated thanos and prevented or
undone his snap by sacrificing only
himself in response the surviving tony
stark dedicated his life and his
intellect to making earth a more
sustainable place but not so fast
because if you look closely at that
statue this doctor strange looks suspect
he has no facial hair like our most
arrogant steven strange's clean shaven
face before his car accident the 2016
film and we know from spiderman no way
home that perfectly grooming his goatee
is a core part of being doctor strange
also this statue has an absurdly tall
collar on the cloak of levitation almost
like a bro peacocking with a collar
popped way over his head and now thanks
to official releases from bunko we know
from a figurine that matches the
statue's clean-shaven face and his
collar that this strange is named
supreme strange now that's not to be
confused with strange supreme the
designation of the doctor strange in
what if episode 4 who's obsessed with
saving christine palmer and absorbing
countless interdimensional beasts to
violate an absolute point that is
apparently a different strange variant
who may also show up in this film i know
strange supreme and supreme strange it's
kind of wacky but i think a that's the
joke and b this statue supreme strange
is intended to be an inverse of strange
supreme but why am i so obsessive about
finding every layer of meaning to this
stuff well it's because i have an innate
fear of missing out i don't want to be
left out in the cold you wanna know what
else is afraid to be left out in the
cold my feetsy weezies i just moved to a
new city it's constantly cold here and
my feet can never get warm but i found
one simple solution to avoiding soggy
socks in wet weather you just wrap your
feet in 40 or 50 layers of plastic
sheeting and duct tape but uh if you're
not into that diy look you gotta wear
some sleek comfortable vessy shoes
instead thank you to bessie for
sponsoring this video besties are the
perfect everyday shoe they are
sustainably made knit sneakers that are
100 waterproof recently wore these
besties on a trip to chicago it's the
middle of winter and they were perfect
they are made with this dimetex material
that's just super easy to clean with a
rinse of water oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
weezies but my oinky oinkies are blown
dry like the dune sea thanks messy
there's no shoes like besties there's no
shoes like besties there's no shoes like
vessies but there are snowshoes like
bessies they aren't as effective at
keeping the snow out though see what i
did there whatever the season vessies
are truly an everyday shoe so banish
those soggy socks forever besties are my
go-to shoes that are right by my door so
check them out in the link below for a
pair of your own bessie shoes strange
supreme was blinded by love and
selfishly destroyed his world but in his
solitude learned from that mistake and
redeemed himself by being a pretty cool
member of the guardians of the
multiverse but supreme strange
contrastingly looks like a selfless hero
who put his world before himself but now
revels in that praise and came out of it
an untested douchebag i mean think about
it it'd be one thing for a doctor
strange statue to commemorate a fallen
martyr but a statue for a guy who
according to his funko figurine is still
alive what does that say about him that
he needs to pass a towering statue of
himself on his way out of the sanctum
every day again all statues are creepy
and by calling him supreme strange i
think this is a doctor strange who
became a sorcerer supreme remember
spider-man no way home established that
since our strange dusted wong became
sorcerer supreme therefore supreme
strange may have come from a universe
where he did not dust and he may have
actually found another way around thanos
to snap but still survived that battle
and ascended to the rank of sorcerer
supreme with his power unquestioned now
looking closely at supreme strange's
wardrobe the blue and white color
palette actually match the colors of the
illuminati citadel the color and the
lighting throughout the british museum
set and the colors worn by christine
palmer as a technician in this facility
she may come from that same reality
where supreme strange ascended to
sorcerer supreme and is now just sucked
into his egotistical orbit it actually
makes sense that in that utopian
universe where supreme strange's sanctum
is located with a below zero carbon
footprint that same strange variant
would model his multiversal illuminati
with perfectly idealized ultron sentries
in the british museum now we know now
that patrick stewart charles xavier does
join this illuminati the guy finally
confirmed it in an interview with jake
hamilton i actually didn't recognize my
own voice it sounded different whether i
had a cold or something at the time i
don't know but i was astonished and all
they saw was the back of my shoulder and
i think my earlobe nothing else that
there would have been so many
connections made it uh it beats me but
it was a hypothetical raised earlier in
this interview that actually gives us
some insight into how charles xavier
might have viewed doctor strange for the
first time meeting him what if
professor x met doctor strange what do
you think would happen professor x would
be
extraordinarily cautious and watchful
and perhaps feel a little insecure
because
there is something that is potentially
dangerous about this man i think that
would put professor xavier on god
interesting words there on god to me
that suggests that either charles xavier
will physically duel with a doctor
strange variant in this movie and that
might be our doctor strange or a
conflict with supreme strange who might
have bullied charles xavier into joining
him in a flawed alliance of this
illuminati which is why we now hear
charles raising his descent during the
tribunal in front of the defendant we
should tell him the truth so obviously
our doctor strange is gonna face several
threats in this film but i think the
trailer footage we've seen has been
super careful to only show us lower
level threats like gargantos and that
ribbon monster and variants of doctor
strange who might seem suspect but might
actually be helpful in some way like
defender strange zombifying himself and
sinister strange now of course wanda
maximov is gonna be a dangerous threat
strange is gonna have to worry about but
i think the true scariest threats of
this film remain in the shadows the real
demonic forces manipulating wanda and
the still unseen members of the
illuminati because if you are still
alive and you need a statue of yourself
you might be the kind of person the
masses eventually revolt against and
topple said statue oh by the way those
funko figurines also teased a mystery
sorcerer named sarah now it could be
sarah wolfe who was wong's one-time love
interest from the comics but she wasn't
a sorcerer this sarah looks like a
sorcerer so let me know your theories of
who this is in the comments below follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars subscribe to the
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you